[Musik]
Ampel in der Krise kein Plan kein Geld
kein Vertrauen Fragezeichen guten Abend
zur zweiten Halbzeit läuft für die
Ampelkoalition und sie beginnt wie die
letzte aufgehört hat mit offenen und
versteckten Fouls an die Teamkollegen
und mit Schüssen auf das eigene Tor
warum sollte das Zusammenspiel in der
Koalition auch besser werden jetzt wo es
ums Geld geht noch mehr Schulden will
man nicht machen höhere Steuern will man
nicht erheben also kürzen wem kann der
Staat noch helfen in Zeiten von
Inflation und Energieknappheit wir
müssen reden mit diesen Gästen
Bundesfinanzminister Christian Lindner
von der FDP
die Grünen Vorsitzende Ricarda lang
der Generalsekretär der CDU Carsten
Linnemann
verena Bentele vom Sozialverband VdK
und die Journalistin
sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit Illner und
die begrüßt noch mal eine Gäste die in
der Sendung ausgesprochen herzlich
Vertrauen ist nicht alles aber ohne
Vertrauen ist alles nicht
Herr je schon wieder derselbe Film mit
denselben Halbstarken und den vielen
Stichwunden
kein Wunder dass die Quoten abschmieren
zuletzt auf 19%
. und nur 14 Prozent glauben dass die
Regierung tatsächlich Probleme löst
[Musik]
wir sind eine Regierung wo
gehämmert geschraubt wird das führt zu
Geräuschen vornehmen ausgedrückt
Lautstärke Krach ums heizungsgesetz vor
der Sommerpause danach Heim nun im
Kindergarten das ist natürlich jetzt
kein Glanzstück gewesen und jetzt
nervöse Schnappatmung beim
industriestrompreis eigentlich braucht
die Ampel ein neues Drehbuch
das geht so nicht weiter die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger sind diesen Stillstand leicht
und ich bin es auch aber im Angebot hat
der Kanzler nur eine neue Requisite
wir werden Hämmern und Klopfen aber mit
Schalldämpfer und einen wenig
originellen neuen Filmtitel ob das
reicht aus diesem alten Schinken wieder
einen Blockbuster zu machen
der deutschland-pakt wird vorgeschlagene
Finanzminister und Parteivorsitzender
der FDP Christian Lindner ist bei uns
Herr Lindner 19 Prozent der Menschen
sagen sie sind noch zufrieden mit dieser
Regierung und 14 Prozent glauben dass
die anstehenden Probleme gelöst werden
durch die Ampel wo ist ihnen das Volk
verloren gegangen warum sagen wir nicht
einfach dafür dass die Probleme gelöst
werden sie sind ja offensichtlich
erstens wir müssen die Migration in
Deutschland unter Kontrolle bekommen
kurz gesagt erleichtern das Fachkräfte
kommen und erleichtern diejenigen die
irregulär in den Sozialstaat
eingewandert sind abschieben zu können
zweitens die Wirtschaft muss in Schwung
kommen wir haben ein Wachstum mit dem
wir nicht zufrieden sein können das hat
konjunkturelle Ursachen Stichwort
wirtschaftliche Lage in China aber auch
strukturelle Probleme in Deutschland die
seit vielen Jahren bekannt sind etwa die
grassierende Bürokratie und jetzt
handeln wir wir haben eine andere
Migrationspolitik wir haben zum Beispiel
mit dem von mir erarbeiteten
wachstumsschancengesetz Impulse für die
Wirtschaft wir beschleunigen die
Planungs- und Genehmigungsverfahren für
erneuerbare Energie und ich schlage vor
einfach stärker über die Probleme als
über Umfragen zu sprechen und genau das
werden wir machen in dieser Sendung sei
das garantiert verena Bentele ist bei
uns die Präsidentin des Sozialverbandes
VdK was die Regierung den Menschen bei
der Lösung und Bewältigung der Krise
auch an Hilfen gegeben hat wird durch
die Inflation und die hohen
Energiepreise bei vielen aufgefressen er
hat man schlicht unterschätzt denken sie
wie groß die
schlichte Angst der Leute ist über den
Monat zu kommen also eine
Herausforderung ist sicherlich dass
viele Menschen
einiges derzeit nicht wirklich verstehen
das Gebäude Energiegesetz ist ein gutes
Beispiel wir haben wirklich zahllose
Briefe im VdK bekommen von Menschen die
uns geschrieben haben ich bin pflegende
Angehörige bin selber 60 Kriege kaum ein
Kredit und nächstes Jahr muss doch jetzt
die Heiz raus bei meinen Eltern die ich
gerade Pflege also haben wir für die
Ampel erklärarbeit gemacht dann gesagt
nee ganz so schlimm ist es jetzt nicht
gerade nicht nächstes Jahr muss die
Heizung raus also ich glaube schon dass
man viel auch damit noch mal
unterstützen und ändern kann dem die
Probleme der Menschen nicht nur gesehen
sondern ihnen dann auch die Lösungen
besser erklärt werden auch das würde
nicht Zufriedenheit doch deutlich
erhöhen das ist mal ein spannender und
wichtiger Punkt und ein anderer ist aber
schon auch dass manche sehr pauschale
Aussagen meines Erachtens hat auch nicht
so richtig zielführend sind jetzt was
man mit Sozialreformen das muss jetzt
mal hier ein Ende haben ist natürlich
für Leute die tatsächlich Unterstützung
brauchen und die haben wir nun mal im
Land ist es jetzt nicht so eine Aussage
die bringt ehrlich gesagt auch wirklich
nichts weil ich meinen starker
Sozialstaat ist auch für eine starke
Wirtschaft im übrigen die
Grundvoraussetzung das kann man ja gar
nicht so trennen wenn wir keine Leute
haben die Kaufkraft haben dann kauft
auch keiner was das ist eine relativ
einfach Rechnung von daher bringt das
meines Erachtens relativ wenig mit
solchen pauschal Aussagen die Leute auf
die Bäume zu treiben und Alltagsstress
war noch mal Zukunftsangst das Stichwort
wenn heute der Vizekanzler ins Parlament
ruft das Land muss raus aus der
Komfortzone und aus der selbst
Zufriedenheit wie viele Leute sind da
ihre Meinung nach noch drin
ja ich wie viele Leute sind da drin also
das Problem ist ja die die Komfortzone
fühlen ja Menschen auch ganz anders und
viele fühlen sich natürlich heute auch
nicht mehr so auch die sogenannte
Mittelschicht hat ja heute ihre Probleme
und
Ängste eben Wohlstand zu verlieren
vielleicht auch nicht mehr so
mitgenommen zu werden nicht dem
Arbeitsmarkt den Anforderungen des
verändernden Arbeitsmarkts gewachsen zu
sein das ist schon eine Herausforderung
die uns alle ja irgendwie auch
Gesellschaft betrifft die wir gemeinsam
anpacken müssen eben dann auch zu
schauen was bedeutet eigentlich wenn
Menschen von Angst getrieben sind und
die Streitigkeiten die jetzt auch in dem
Film gerade angesprochen wurden haben in
meinen Augen vor allem eins zu Folge
dass die Unzufriedenheit damit
eigentlich nur geschürt wird und wie
viel über den Streit sprechen wir
sollten aber viel mehr darüber sprechen
was die Lösung sind was wir was ja auch
an guten passiert aber was auch noch
passieren muss und das konstruktiv zu
diskutieren bringt viel mehr wie bei
Maßnahmen wie den Bürgergeld zu sagen
bringt doch alles nichts das Bürgergeld
die Leute soll man arbeiten gehen ja
selten so gelacht wenn es so einfach
wäre dann hätten die Leute ja alle einen
Job und hätten nicht die Probleme
deswegen ist für mich immer eher die
Frage was bieten wir den Menschen an an
Qualifizierung an Möglichkeiten
irgendwie klar zu kommen reden wir auch
noch drüber Ricarda langes bei uns eine
der zwei Vorsitzenden von Bündnis 90 die
Grünen Frau lang egal ob Corona Ukraine
Krieg oder auch der Klimaschutz die
Leute waren mehrheitlich in diesem Land
eigentlich immer an der Seite der Ampel
wenn es um den Sinn und und diese Ziele
gingen auch an Sie die Frage warum haben
sie zwischendurch das Volk verloren ich
glaube wenn er auf die Ziele schauen
dann ist das nach wie vor ein ganz ganz
vielen Stellen so und ich will mal sagen
ich habe diese Woche in den
haushaltsverhandlung keine Koalition
erlebt die sie mit selbst beschäftigt
sondern mit dem Problem und vor allem
auch mit den Lösungen beschäftigt es
wurde gerade im Film gesagt das wurde
gehämmert und Geburt im letzten Jahr und
woran liegt das dass wir ja schon aus
der Komfortzone rausgegangen sind da wir
uns nicht weiter vor unbequemen Fragen
Eindruck haben Fachkräftemangel wie
gestaltet man Einwanderungsland
erneuerbare Energien galt lange Noten
mal backyard abstrakt waren alle dafür
konkret wurde wenig
umgesetzten
und das haben wir als Ampel jetzt
geändert das ist gut ich glaube für die
Zukunft muss noch mehr gelten wenn ich
mit Bürgerinnen und Bürger im Land rede
dann wollen die nicht wissen ist das ein
grüner Erfolg ist das ein gelber Erfolg
oder ist das ein roter Erfolg die wollen
wissen was bringt es für mich und das
sollten wir nach vorne stellen also
nicht die eigene Partei sondern das Land
noch mal die Frage warum sagt der
Vizekanzler und der ähm
Wirtschaftsminister das Land muss raus
aus der Komfortzone sehr selbst
Zufriedenheit ist jetzt irgendwie wir
werden jetzt die Bürger bestimmt nein
darum geht es ja überhaupt nicht sondern
ehrlich gesagt wenn man sich die Politik
der Regierung davor anschaut dann hat
man sich da ja ganz häufig bewegen
gemacht ein Beispiel dafür ist die
Abhängigkeit von russischen Gas ja
wusste man eigentlich wie verwundbar und
das macht die gefährlich das ist aber es
war kurzzeitig billig und da haben wir
jetzt gesagt wir nehmen eben nicht mehr
die einfachste Route von diesem Ziel
führt besonders motivierend ist es ja
nicht egal wenn man so ein Satz ins
Klare motivieren ist zu sagen das können
wir hinbekommen und da will ich mal
sagen ich habe in den letzten Wochen
häufig erlebt gerade aus ihrer Partei
dass das Land ein bisschen schlecht
geredet wurde der kranke Mann Europas
ein Land und dann schauen muss die Leute
nicht zu faul sind ich glaube dass wir
ein starkes Land haben mit einer starken
Wirtschaft und dass wir das was wir
jetzt hinbekommen haben also zu sagen
auch die schwierigen Entscheidung
anzugehen dass wir es hinbekommen können
aber da bin ich bei Frau Bentele dabei
muss es gerecht zugeben Kassen Lindemann
ist bei uns neuer CDU Generalsekretär
seit Juli dieses Jahres hat die CDU
Grundwerte Kommission geleitet und das
Grundsatz Papier erarbeitet aus der
Enttäuschung über die Ampelmann ist
keine Begeisterung für die CDU und keine
für Friedrich Merz geworden da musste
Generalsekretär der neue Generalsekretär
jetzt richten
nein ich glaube schon dass man mit dem
Ampel gesetzt wo die Ampeln halbes Jahr
darüber gestritten hat
das Morgen verabschiedet wird was immer
noch für eine völlige Verunsicherung
wird und gleichzeitig das einzige was
man jetzt geschafft hat ist an einem
Gesetz zu arbeiten in Sachen
Legalisierung von Drogen
Christian Lindner hat die
wirtschaftliche Situation erkannt mit
seinem wachstumschancengesetz der
diskutieren wir auch darüber wie wir
damit umgehen da sind viele gute Punkte
drin aber der Kanzlei eben nicht ich
habe gestern den Plenum gesessen ich
muss das wirklich so hart sagen
ernegiert die aktuelle Situation ich
habe das Gefühl dass er im Kanzleramt
sitzt und nicht mit den Bürgern redet
mit den mittelständlernen
in Deutschland packt vor also nicht nur
Ihnen aber auch der Opposition dieses
Landes Jens Spahn hat gleich gesagt das
ist ein offenbarungseidnis dass der
Bundeskanzler sich an sämtliche Länder
und auch kommunalen Einheiten wendet
aber auch an die Opposition sagen sie
das auch es ist ein offenbar sie können
sogar noch weitergehen eigentlich ist es
ein Misstrauensvotum gegenüber der Ampel
gegenüber den eigenen Leuten es ist ein
Hilfe ruf ich meine er fordert uns auf
mitzumachen wir haben bewiesen in den
letzten Monaten in den letzten zwei
Jahren dass wenn es darauf ankommt wir
da sind Sachen Ukraine Bundeswehr
aber er muss die Situation natürlich
sehen ich sag mal zum Beispiel Migration
wir haben jetzt aufgelaufen 80% mehr
Asylanträge in Deutschland als im
letzten Jahr und das Jahr ist noch nicht
zu Ende die Bürgermeister die Landrätin
melden sich er hat einen großen
flüchtlingsgipfel gemacht am 10 Mai hat
heilig was versprochen nichts passiert
wir könnten jetzt sofort und dann würden
wir auch sofort mit der Ampel reden
beispielsweise Grenzkontrollen an der
Grenze Polen Deutschland Tschechien
Deutschland sichere Herkunftsstaaten ähm
Sachleistungen beim Bürgergeld spüren
wir doch das ist eine Anziehung ist wir
würden da sofort agieren aber der
Kanzler muss es wollen und er muss die
Situation sehen auch wirtschaftlich ich
meine wir sind der kranke Mann Europas
sogar weltweit unter den
Industriestaaten schrumpfen wir vom
Wachstum die große Industrie kann im
Ausland investieren die kleinen
Mittelständler sind hier die zum Teil
leise Sterben der sagt ein
Metzgermeister in meiner Region die
beste Entscheidung meines Lebens war den
Laden abzuschließen und ich bin dass
meine Kinder was anderes machen dieses
Land muss aus dieser Lethargie raus auch
die Oppositionen Einsatz sagen zum
Kanzler und zu dem deutschland-pakt
Carsten Linnemann hat ja gerade
dankenswerterweise gesagt dass das
wachstumschancengesetz dass die
Bundesregierung vorgelegt hat Impulse
setzt für Investitionen auch für
Forschung den Mittelstand stärkt und ich
glaube es ist ein wichtiges Element
jetzt einer Strategie die Wirtschaft
voranzubringen aber wir müssen auch
wahrnehmen dass CDU-geführte
Bundesländer wie Schleswig-Holstein und
Berlin offen lassen ob Sie dem zustimmen
und wenn hier der Kanzler sagt wir
brauchen einen Pakt zwischen Bund und
Ländern und solche ja auch von der
cdu/csu Bundestagsfraktion als richtig
Erkannte Initiativen umzusetzen dann
glaube ich wird daraus ein Schuh jetzt
muss es wirklich darum gehen dass wir
das Notwendige tun übrigens auch in der
Migrationspolitik kann viel von dem auch
unterstützen haben warum machen was dann
nicht kontrollieren
das ist jetzt ein Instrument ganz
wichtiges auf der europäischen Ebene
eine ganz andere Migrationspolitik haben
als mit Verlaub zu Zeiten der Ära Merkel
manches mehr wäre möglich und insofern
kann auch das Bestandteil einer
intensiven Zusammenarbeit zwischen Bund
und Ländern sein und ich bin ganz bei
dem was Ricarda lang eben gesagt hat da
soll es nicht darauf ankommen wer hat
das Urheberrecht für eine gute Idee
entscheidend muss sein dass wir die
Lösung bekommen ja und die Länder haben
ja was vorgelegt vor acht neun Monaten
wie man Genehmigungsverfahren
planungsbeschleunigung vorantreibt keine
Antwort vom Kanzler ich habe noch mit
Hendrik wüst gestern gesprochen er weil
er hat mitgemacht nichts am 10 Mai auch
es passiert einfach nicht dieses Land
steht
Frage aber das erste noch mal und zwar
an beide Politiker bevor wir die
Journalistin unbedingt noch begrüßen
Misstrauensvotum sagt Katzen Dendemann
eigentlich ist es ein Misstrauensvotum
gegen die Ampel wenn der Bundeskanzler
sich mit der Opposition und
die Bundesländern so ins Benehmen setzen
wir fühlen Sie sich angesprochen nein
überhaupt nicht das ist ja klar bei dem
was wir uns vorgenommen haben und ich
finde übrigens das Infrastruktur gerade
einen der Bereich ist wo die Ampel
vorangeht wir haben
planungsbeschleunigung
Genehmigungsverfahren die lange
verstarbt haben die ewig gedauert haben
bei einer erneuerbaren Energien beim
Ausbau der schien jetzt endlich auf den
Weg gebracht aber das ist so kompliziert
dass das nicht einfach mal ein
Bundesgesetz ist sondern braucht es das
Land die Länder da braucht es die
Kommunen und die einzuladen zu sagen wir
machen das gemeinsam und dabei geht's
natürlich auch
eine Verantwortung das noch sagen darf
denn sie sagen es geht auch um
Sicherheit geben muss die muss natürlich
auch mit einer Opposition gehen da hat
eine konservative Partei eine ganz
zentrale Rolle zu spielen aber da muss
ich sagen wenn ich ihre gerade sehe dann
sehe ich dann Richtung Streit will man
in der Mitte bleiben und Verantwortung
übernehmen diesen vielen Landesregierung
getan wird oder redet man von Gilla muss
statt Kreuzberg redet man von sozial
Tourismus macht die Grünen zum
Hauptgegner mit denen so viele Ländern
das ist doch Entscheidung von der sie
gerade stehen im Kanzler Verantwortung
übernommen hat das Gespräch mit dem
Kanzler gesucht und ganz klar dieses
Zeichen zu setzen und mit Kreuzberg
wollte er deutlich machen dass diese
Ampel zunehmend Politik macht für große
Städte es gibt ein ländlichen Raum wenn
Sie einen ein Ticket für ein ÖPNV von 49
Euro umsetzen ich komme aus dem
ländlichen Raum dann sagen die Leute zu
mir es ist alles gut und schön aber die
Busse fahren nicht ihr macht das nur für
die großen Städte und das wollte er
deutlich machen und wenn man bei einer
bierzeltrede einfach mal zuspitzt lassen
Sie doch mal die Kirche im Dorf einfach
mal machen anstatt über uns zu reden
wir hatten meine konservative Partei die
wollte für das ganze Land Politik machen
und zwar egal ob für Berlin oder Bayern
egal wie die Leute den großen Städten
leben oder die im ländlichen Raum reden
und wenn man jetzt anfängt einzuteilen
was ist normal wer gehört dazu für wen
macht ein Polizei
machen
muss und genau dafür müssen
auf der Strecke der ländliche Raum da
reden wir gerade noch drüber in
Haushaltsverhandlungen dass wir jetzt
noch mal etwas drauflegen wenn man
glauben
Infrastruktur Entschuldigung wichtige
Informationen was haben die Herren
ausgetauscht die haben über die aktuelle
Situation gesprochen und Friedrich Merz
hat deutlich gemacht das was ich gerade
gesagt habe dass bei den großen
Herausforderungen ich habe das Thema
Migration angesprochen das sage ich auch
wirklich als als Bürger in meiner Region
werden im Moment zur Verfügung gestellt
die jungen Leute können da nicht mehr
hingehen wir haben eine Überforderung in
Deutschland
Schüler die nicht mehr zur Schule gehen
weil die Kapazitäten nicht da muss man
doch mal ehrlich diese Positionen 2015
portfolgende wir machen jetzt machen
eine andere Migrationspolitik das muss
man schon sagen endlich ist passiert so
viel Neues das jetzt endlich reinkommt
und wir einmal fragen
Chefin Chefredakteurin des
redaktionsnetzwerk ist Deutschland
Chefin hier im Hauptstadtstudio sowieso
dieser Redaktion die Ampel warum ist das
Vertrauen Weg der Bürger in diese
Regierung
die Ampel hat in den vergangenen Jahr
knapp zwei Jahren anderthalb Jahre die
sie jetzt regiert nicht zeigen können
dass sie tatsächlich in der Lage ist
Probleme zu lösen auf dem
Koalitionsvertrag steht
fortschrittskoalition und genau dieser
Fortschritt ist bisher nicht spürbar
eingetreten für die Leute und dann kommt
tatsächlich dieser destruktive Streit
hinzu denn die Ampel ausgetragen hat
monatelang über verschiedene Themen
gipfelte immer wieder im Streit über das
Energiegesetz aber man könnte auch noch
viele andere Themen nennen und es ist ja
gut wenn verschiedene Positionen
zusammenkommen und man sich das beste
raussucht und das war ja auch die Idee
von dieser fortschrittskoalition aber es
hat einfach nicht geklappt und sie
kriegen es nicht hin und sie haben sich
sehr verhakt und
kommt können diesen Knoten nicht
auflösen und dann gab es einen Kanzler
der immer mal wieder eingegriffen hat
und sogar seine Richtlinienkompetenz
zücken musste in dem Streit um die
Atomkraft aber die Dinge eben auch nicht
voranbringen konnte und sehr oft hat
Scholz eigentlich so große tubeweise
Salbe rausgeholt und gesagt das ist
alles in Ordnung und ich fand
interessant dass er jetzt gerade in der
Generaldebatte am Mittwoch da ein
Strategiewechsel vorgenommen hat der hat
erstmals die Situation wie das Land
dasteht wirklich sehr ehrlich sehr
transparent beschrieben und dann alle
Ebenen in diesem Land Kommunen Länder
und auch seine eigene Ampel aufgerufen
für ein deutschlandpackt und die
Opposition eben auch dazu eingeladen und
ich denke dass das tatsächlich dringend
nötig ist natürlich kann man sagen okay
das nächste große Wort von Scholz der
immer gerne mit großen Worten operiert
wenn die Krise auch groß ist aber er hat
es ganz anders intoniert als sonst und
ich finde es wären alle gut beraten da
tatsächlich versuchen mitzumachen und
dann an einzelnen politischen Problemen
anzusetzen man wird nicht also es wird
jetzt nicht sinnvoll sein wenn sich
Kommunen Länder und Bund an einen Tisch
setzen und versuchen irgendetwas hinzu
kommen sondern es wäre wichtig in
einzelnen Gruppen die Probleme dann zu
lösen und da da voranzugehen damit die
Leute im Land merken schnell merken dass
ich etwas ändert weil es ist tatsächlich
etwas ins Rutschen gekommen in
Deutschland und da bin ich sehr der
Meinung dass man sich die Umfragen genau
angucken sollte und auch genau hinhören
sollte was die Leute über die Regierung
sagen weil nur so wird man sie wieder
erreichen und das Vertrauen auch zurück
weil dieses
wird ja eben morgen tatsächlich im
Bundestag wird darüber abgestimmt also
ob es durchgewunken wird dieses Gefühl
um das Gebäude Energiegesetz das
berühmte heizungsgesetz war das so zu
sagen ein Knackpunkt wo die Leute
einfach ausgecheckt sind
das vor allen Dingen das Hin und Her
also die verschiedenen Pläne die nach
und nach bekannt geworden sind haben die
Leute tatsächlich profund verunsichert
also ich habe es auch in meinem eigenen
Bekanntenkreis kamen die Menschen auf
mich zu irgendetwas bedeutet das denn
jetzt wirklich fürchten wirklich wir
können uns das nicht leisten und
leider ist das Gebäude Energiegesetz
auch von seiner Wirkung nach hinten
losgegangen weil anstatt dass man
Werbung macht für Klimaschutz den wir
wirklich brauchen in diesem Land und wir
brauchen auch Menschen die sich leisten
können die dann eben bereit sind in
ihren Häusern umzubauen und das es hat
vor allen Dingen sehr viel Widerstand
hervorgerufen die Art wie die Debatte
geführt wurde und auch die Art wie ein
Gesetzentwurf nach dem anderen kam und
wenn das jetzt Morgen verabschiedet wird
dann
wird man eine Luft ja und mit diesem
Gesetz wird viel weniger erreicht als
ohai darum gemacht wurde und vor allen
Dingen auch als der politische Preis der
für dieses Gesetz bezahlt wird und da
ist die Frage nicht und ich meine sie
genauso wie ich sie Stelle ist das ein
entscheiden der Kipppunkt gewesen Herr
Lindner das monatelange streiten und
verhandeln um dieses Gesetz und war es
ein am Ende auch ein Booster für die AFD
ich sehe es genau andersrum wäre das
Gesetz so beschlossen worden wie es
vorgelegt worden ist dann hätten wir in
unserem Land ein massives Problem mit
der Akzeptanz für den Klimaschutz gehabt
ich sag ja nicht dass das Gesetz so wie
es zuerst vorgelegt wurde gut war das
war natürlich auch da schon schlimm dass
das in diesem Zustand an die
Öffentlichkeit gegangen ist in der in
der es noch nicht geeint wurde da wäre
es schon besser gewesen wenn es die
Ministerien hinbekommen hätten sich erst
einmal stillschweigend hinter den
Kulissen auf Verbesserungen zu einigen
und dann damit an die Öffentlichkeit zu
gehen aber es ist ja ganz offensichtlich
aus der Regierung liegt worden ohne dass
ich jetzt sagen kann aus welchem
Ministerium es gelegt worden ist aber
das war ja die Regierung selbst und da
sind die Leute ja sehr schlau und wissen
dass da offensichtlich man sich
gegenseitig die Knüppel zwischen das
ganze was heißt nein das kann ich so
nicht nicht Kunden was heißt es wurde
gelegt es gab einen Gesetzentwurf der
Bundesregierung der im Wissen darum dass
es innerhalb des Kabinetts keine
Einigkeit gab ans Parlament gegangen ist
ich persönlich bin gebeten worden den
Weg frei zu machen für die
parlamentsberatung obwohl ich
schwerwiegende Bedenken hatte das würde
ich das würde ich würde ich im übrigen
keinesfalls noch mal so mitmachen ich
wollte konstruktiv sein Okay es soll in
die parlamentsberatung würde ich kein
zweites Mal machen deshalb haben wir ja
auch bei der Kindergrundsicherung länger
gebraucht bis wir zueinander gekommen
sind aber in der Sache will ich noch mal
unterstreichen
man muss zwei Dinge doch
unterstreichen den Prozess wo ich ihn
recht gebe das würde ich nie noch einmal
so sehen und wünsche mir auch dass ich
so etwas nicht wiederholt und zum
anderen das Ergebnis und das erste
sozusagen
der SPD Bundestagsfraktion diese Woche
denn man kann nicht von den Bürgern
etwas verlangen bevor nicht der Staat
seine Hausaufgaben gemacht hat Stichwort
kommunale wärmeplanung die Wärmepumpe
ist nicht für jedes Gebäude geeignet
nicht in jedem Gebäude ist es überhaupt
wirtschaftlich so weitgehende
Sanierungsmaßnahmen zu machen die Frage
der Förderung musste geklärt werden ich
könnte die Liste weiter fortsetzen und
jetzt ist dieses Gesetz so dass es die
soziale Akzeptanz sichert weil es
physikalisch technisch ökonomisch
vernünftig ist ob sie auch das Gefühl
haben dass dieses Gesetz jetzt so viel
besser ist ich habe das Gefühl dass ein
gutes Gesetz haben dann das Ziel war ja
eine Kostenfalle zu verhindern also dass
Leute auf 500 Gas und Ölpreisen belastet
werden und gleichzeitig ein Umstieg auf
klimafreundliches heizen bezahlbar zu
machen da haben wir jetzt ein Gesetz
dass durch durch die Kopplungen an die
kommunale Wärme bleiben noch mal
pragmatischer geworden wir haben die
Förderung miteinander geklärt es gibt
unterschiedliche Möglichkeiten ich
glaube aber zum Prozess kann man sagen
Christian Lindner hat mal als wir
gemeinsam ein Ergebnis eines Koalition
vorgestellt haben gesagt man schweigt
sich auseinander man redet sich zusammen
oder diskutiert sich zusammen manchmal
könnten wir wahrscheinlich dass
diskutieren mehr hinter verschlossenen
Türen das Schweigen mehr auf Twitter
machen ja ich erinnere sogar auch das
Ende dieses Koalitionsausschusses noch
nach 30 Stunden und das hat vielleicht
nicht mehr jeder Bürger so auf der
Platte aber auf jeden Fall war es ein
tatsächlich sehr langer Prozess wichtig
ist dass jetzt auch die Grünen sagen es
ist ein Gesetz hinter dem sie
vollständig stehen und sagen es ist auch
praktischer pragmatische als das was
quasi die erste Vorlage war man hätte
auch sagen können nur mal so als Gedanke
als Regierung sagen können das ist
übrigens unser Plan bei allen Neubauten
hier sind jetzt zehn Firmen aus
Deutschland ähm bei denen sie sich
melden können wenn es Neubauten gibt
hier sind 10 Produkte hier sind zehn
Wärme vom projektprodukte die sich
sofort einbauen lassen und die Kollegen
da helfen Ihnen eben auch die
entsprechenden Subventionen die schon
verabredet haben an den Start zu kriegen
so etwas hätte man weil es ein bisschen
länglich hingestellt so etwas hätte man
natürlich auch machen können man hätte
einfach sagen können wir wollen dass das
kommt wir wollen dass es ab 1.1.24 kommt
und es wäre super wenn man dem Bürger
zeitgleich ein praktikablen weggewiesen
hätte wie er sich darum kümmern kann
indem man sagt welche Firmen das Bauen
wo man diese Wärmepumpen her bekommt und
wie man gleichzeitig noch vermeiden muss
und kann dass man durch dieses
bafamarschiert und zehn Monate auf die
Genehmigung einer Subvention war ich
würde gerne eine Sache ergänzen was für
viele Menschen glaube ich eine zunehmen
das Problem wird gerade wenn die
Diskussion eben so laufen wie es in dem
Gebäude Energiegesetz war halt viele das
Problem dass sie eigentlich das Gefühl
haben sie können nicht mithalten sie
können keinen Beitrag leisten zum
Klimawandel es ist wird irgendwie mit
Sanktion belegt mit Verboten die Heizung
darf nicht mehr betrieben werden das ist
das ob das jetzt stimmt oder nicht was
bei den Menschen hängen bleibt und
niemand würde aufstehen und sagen okay
ich bin nicht dafür für
klimafreundlicher zu heizen da würde
erstmal keiner den Raum verlassen wenn
es aber dann darum geht wie setzt du es
um kriegst du eine Förderung kriegen
vielleicht auch Menschen die wenig Geld
haben mehr Förderung können auch ältere
Menschen noch Kredit bekommen das sind
ja die Fragen die die Menschen am Ende
wirklich umtreiben und da bringt glaube
ich am Ende auch da nichts so ein
Vorhaben immer so grundsätzlich in Frage
zu stellen und mit ist einfach Praktika
praktikabel zu machen genau Herr
Lindemann interessant an der Opposition
ist dass die CDU das verbesserte Gesetz
ähm jetzt nur stoppen will wenn sie an
der Regierung wäre ich hoffe ich zitiere
korrekt dass das ihr Ziel ist wenn sie
an die Regierung kommen möchten Sie das
GEG äh anzünden stoppen keine Ahnung
warum wollen sie es nicht mehr verändern
das wäre ja auch ein parlamentarischer
gerade ganz wichtiger sprechen also ich
stehe nicht für einen Staat der sagt
hier sind zehn Firmen hier sind vier in
der Wärmepumpen entscheidet euch das
muss technologieoffen sein und ich empf
also keine Firmen sondern es muss immer
Innovationen passieren und so weiter 24
eine Innovation möchte und die quasi
selbst festlegen
wir gar nicht wir möchten gar nicht
einseitig nur die Wärmepumpe wir wollen
auch Heizung mit Holz ermöglichen es
wird sogar möglich sein es wird es wird
sogar nein was heißt nicht so viel Zeit
es gibt keine Festlegung auf eine
Technologie und es gibt auch kein Verbot
für irgendeine Technologie
so richtig praktikabel ich glaube man
hat es verstanden oder so richtig
praktikabel war es nicht es gab eine
Anhörung mit mit 20 Fachleuten die haben
alle gesagt es ist nicht praktikabel und
sozial nicht ausgeglichen ich meine sie
sagen sie haben ja mit den Menschen viel
Kontakt ich habe es über E-Mail auch in
Gesprächen die haben nicht mal eben
10.000 von Euro jetzt und es kann auch
irgendwie ein älterer kein Kredit nehmen
die haben ihr Hausarzt bezahlt haben
Sorge dass jemand ins Pflegeheim kommt
da muss man noch mal drei 4000 €
hinzunehmen äh in zuzahlen und jetzt
diese unsicher Zeit und bei den
Förderprogrammen also ich habe heute
gelesen dass man dass man dass man 30
Prozent gefördert bekommt und noch 30
Prozent wenn man 40.000 Euro brutto
nicht überschreitet das ist noch niemals
durchschnittsbrutto Jahresgehalt ich
sage Ihnen das wird eine Verunsicherung
haben weil die Leute einfach bei 6 7
Prozent Inflation völlig überfordert
sind und was passiert denn morgen Frau
lang wo sollen denn die Leute anrufen
morgen kommen die ganzen Mails die
kriegen wir Abgeordneten an wen soll ich
mich melden gibt es einen werbeplan im
in meiner Kommune bin ich überhaupt
erfasst oder nicht oder kann ich warten
wo melden sie sich
Menschen das Wirtschaftsministerium die
werden rausgegeben das heißt da findet
man genau Informationen was steht im
Gesetz auch ein paar Fehlinformationen
die gerne auch mal verbreitet wurde denn
so getan wurde als ob irgendwelche
Heizung rausgerissen wurden was nie
gestimmt hat
Informationen was mache ich Förderung
das kommt drauf an wann die Kommunen
eine kommunale wärmeplanung da kann man
direkt Bürgermeister ans Rathaus wenden
das ist unterschiedlich als wenn ich ihn
mal schauen Baden-Württemberg zum
Beispiel wird das jetzt schon ungefähr
bis zum Ende dieses Jahres wir haben ein
paar andere Länder z.B Bayern die sind
sehr weit hinterher aber Stück für Stück
wird jede Kommune eine kommunale
wärmeplanung vorlegen ab einer
bestimmten Größe und das ist ja auch das
Beste was passieren kann wenn am Ende
nicht nur jeder einzeln für sich eine
Lösung finden muss sondern man als
Kommune gemeinsam schaut am besten mit
einer Fernwärme gibt's auch neue
Möglichkeiten
gibt
andere erfüllungsoptionen und war gerade
gesagt worden ist was passiert morgen
oder am ersten des nächsten Jahres
nichts
weil wenn keine kommunale wärmeplanung
vorliegt dann bleiben alle
erfüllungsoptionen offen und man muss ja
Ehrlichkeit halber auch sagen wer ein
neues Haus baut oder er eine kaputter
Heizung ersetzen muss der muss auch
investieren wenn eine der Unterschied
ist nur wir haben jetzt zukünftig eine
höhere Förderung als unter in jetzt
geltenden Regeln das heißt für
diejenigen die ohnehin die Heizung
erneuern müssen verbessert sich etwas
und deshalb stand vorher 50 nur noch mal
dass wir deshalb bin ich das bis zu 75%
bei jenen die eine besondere
förderbedürftigkeit haben aber ich finde
das auch richtig denn wir müssen schon
unterscheiden zwischen denjenigen wo ähm
es wirkliche Bedürftigkeit gibt was wir
nicht machen können ist eine
Gesellschaft wo alle jeden
subventionieren bei denen die Wirtschaft
nicht leistungsfähig sind muss es einen
Unterschied machen das ist ja völlig
klar so und sie sind auf der anderen
Seite das habe ich irgendwie gerade auch
verstanden ist ein sehr froh dass zum
ersten eben erst mal nichts passiert
sondern eben gefühlt 99 Monat der
Diskussion diese kommunale wärmeplanung
endlich genommen wurde um ja etwas sehr
logisches vorzuschlagen nämlich warum
sollen eigentlich Millionen Deutsche
sich eine ratternde Wärmepumpe an den
Balkon kleben wenn es eine kommunale
wärmeplanung gibt man muss man muss ja
wissen wird mein Erdgasnetz hier
irgendwann mit
klimafreundlichen Gasen betrieben werden
wird mein bisheriges Erdgasnetz
vielleicht umgestellt auf Wasserstoff in
den 30er Jahren und dann kann ich eine
Entscheidung treffen über meine Heizung
die ich 20 Jahre und länger haben will
sonst geht das ja nicht sonst würde man
einseitig die Menschen in Richtung der
Strom betriebenen Wärmepumpe lenken und
das kann ich sinnvoll sein dass auch
nicht jedes Gebäude geeignet und das ist
ein ganz grundlegender Wechsel und ich
verstehe die Verunsicherung auf die
Verbände hingewiesen hat sie ist da
aufgrund der Debatte aber mit dem Gesetz
wie es jetzt ist gibt es diese
Verunsicherung nicht mehr es muss sie
nicht mehr geben so und dann sind wir
vor Quadbeck noch einmal bei dem was so
deutlich wird an der Diskussion um
dieses Gesetz im Grunde hat der Bürger
ja zunächst verstanden ein Großteil
dieser großen Transformation wird in den
privaten Schoß des Bürgers gelegt und er
hat ihn zu einem großen Teil auch zu
bezahlen hat sich davon der Bürger noch
nicht richtig erholt glauben Sie also
ist das einer der Gründe diese
Verunsicherung da kommen ja verschiedene
Dinge zusammen also der
Wohlstandsverlust über den wir immer
sprechen der ist ja längst im Gang also
durch die Inflation und auch dadurch
dass klar ist dass eben russisches Gas
nicht mehr fließen wird und dass die
Energiepreise auf jeden Fall hoch
bleiben unabhängig davon mit welchen
Technologien also sie werden hoch
bleiben egal ob ich jetzt in Klimaschutz
investiere oder ob ich weiter mit
gasheizen und
viele Menschen merken einfach dass das
total schwierig ist den Alltag mit den
zu Verfügung stehenden finanziellen
Mitteln so zu bewältigen wie das vor
zwei drei vier Jahren noch ging und dann
kommt eben dazu dass wir Moment eine
Regierung haben die durch ihre
chaotische Art der Gesetzgebung einfach
zusätzlich für Verunsicherung sorgt und
dann haben wir uns in den merkeljahren
daran gewöhnt dass jedes Problem das
auftaucht einfach mal mit Geld erledigt
wird weil es war sehr viel Geld da und
strukturellen Probleme die unsere
Volkswirtschaft hat die waren relativ
gut zugedeckt dadurch dass der Export so
gebrummt hat und deshalb die Wirtschaft
so gut gelaufen kann die Zinsen
zusätzlich noch nicht daran und dann
haben uns die haben die Amerikaner auch
noch unsere Sicherheit ähm
gesichert so und all das ist weg und das
wissen die Leute also Wohlstand und
Sicherheit stehen so ganz groß einfach
mal in Frage und wenn dann Regierung da
ist die nicht Sicherheit vermittelt
sondern die Unsicherheit vermittelt dann
potenziert sich das und das führt zu
dieser zu diesem großen
Vertrauensverlust den wir Moment haben
und der sich eben in den hohen
Zustimmungsraten für die AFD
niederschlägt und da ist was ins rutscht
gekommen es gab nur einen Unterschied
Frau Quadbeck die letzte große Rezession
war 2009 - 6% werden sechs sieben große
Rezessionen nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
bis heute bei dieser großen Rezession
wurde sofort gehandelt wir haben die
Situation erkannt mit Herrn Steinbrück
die Konten sind sicher es gab einen
Wachstumsbeschleunigungsgesetz es gab
ein Unternehmen Steuerreform und die
Schuldenbremse und dann hatten wir 10
Jahre Wachstum befeuert durch eine
niedrigste Politik ja aber jetzt haben
wir wieder eine Rezession und jetzt
legiert der Kanzler diese Lage der will
das gar nicht wahrnehmen und wir haben
keine schlechte Wirtschaft wir haben
eine wir haben eine schlechte Regierung
sein das ist sehr schwierig zuzuhören
weil Herr Scholz nie konkret wird er ist
immer auf so einer Flughöhe unterwegs
ich will wissen was machen wir denn
jetzt damit wir ein Pakt für die
fleißigen bekommen das
überstundensteuerfrei sind das Rentnern
Freibetrag bekommen dass wir das
Bürgergeld reformieren dass ich
Anstrengung wieder lohnt das ist ja in
diesem Lande mit dem Bürgermeister
geworden
Punkt es begann mit dem Bürgergeld das
war irgendwie so ein Begriff was
suggerierte es steht ein zu dann gibt es
eine ganze Debatte um die vier Tage
Woche bei vollen Lohnausgleich es gibt
einige bei Ihnen in einer Partei die das
bedingungslose Grundeinkommen wollen ich
meine es ist ja auch in der Gesellschaft
die Bundesjugendspiele sollen
abgeschafft werden weil keiner meine
Ehrenurkunde bekommen da und der DFB
denkt darüber nach dass Tore nicht
Mercedes was ist los in diesem Land
dafür müssen sie stehen dafür müssen sie
kämpfen wir können die
bundeswirtschaftliche Situation
starke Wirtschaft haben es stimmt aber
tatsächlich dass wir geraden Situation
haben die Wachstumsraten vergleichen wo
wir hinterherhinken bei vielen anderen
Länder ist auch klar wenn wir mehr
Gerechtigkeit wollen müssen wir wieder
auf dem Wachstumskurs kommen und dann
reden wir bitte nicht über
Bundesjugendspiele sondern reden wir
auch ganz konkret was man machen muss
das erste sind bezahlbare Energiepreise
da diskutieren wir gerade wie man es vor
allem für die Brücke der nächsten Jahre
hinbekommen kann das zweite ist mehr
Fachkräfte zu hebeln auf
Einwanderungsgesetz Fachkräfte passiert
jetzt reden wir über Kita-Ausbau wir
sprechen darüber Anreize für ältere
Menschen zu machen das dritte ist die
Frage wie wir Investitionen Hebeln
können diese Situation eine
Infrastruktur zu machen und das vierte
und da sprechen über das Wohlstand das
stimmt ja wenn Wohlstand einfach
abstrakte Begriff ist aber diejenigen
die in der Arbeiten zu wenig davon
profitieren dann geht dieses Versprechen
nicht auf das heißt wir brauchen
Gerechtigkeit zu sprechen deshalb
bringen wir jetzt ein Paket für Tarif
teuer auf dem Weg damit endlich wieder
mehr Menschen nach Tarif bezahlt werden
in diesem Land also auch gut bezahlt
werden das sind konkrete Dinge die
Menschen wirklich helfen besser das Land
irgendwie faul zu reden
die Regierung nicht schlecht nicht das
Land das Land ist sie müssen einfach mal
machen sie regieren seit zwei Jahren
beschreiben super die Probleme einfach
mal machen das waren keine Probleme wir
sind an der Stelle wo wir zu guterhalten
wollen dass der Bundesfinanzminister in
dieser Sendung ist sie haben und
unbedingt in diesem sie haben genau in
dieser Woche den Haushalt vorgestellt
auch das war monatelang um kämpfen wenn
dieses Thema wechseln darf ich noch eine
Sache hinzufügen bei was schon bisschen
schwierig ist immer zu so gering das
Land muss ich wieder für fleißige Lohn
wir haben riesen Niedriglohnsektor wir
haben Leute die viel arbeiten schlechter
dafür bezahlt werden also wenn man sowas
wenn ich sowas immer höre dass ärgert
mich dann schon ein bisschen muss ich
sagen das soll sich wieder Lohn für die
fleißigen es gibt hier ganz schön viele
Menschen die sind fleißig müssen
trotzdem mit Sozialhilfe mit Bürgergeld
aufstocken
da ist das stimmt doch beides wir haben
Menschen die können mit ihrer
Lebenssituation nicht zufrieden sein und
bemühen sich sehr wir haben übrigens
auch erhebliche Integrationsprobleme
Menschen die zu uns gekommen sind und im
Arbeitsmarkt notorisch nicht Fuß fassen
aber wir haben eben auch eine eine
breite Mittelschicht von Menschen die
ordentlich verdienen die aber im
europäischen Vergleich höchste Steuern
und Sozialabgaben zahlen und die fragen
sich natürlich schon bei meinen hohen
Steuern und Sozialabgaben was bekomme
ich dafür an öffentlichen Leistungen wie
leistungsfähig ist der Staat und wie
komme ich selbst wirtschaftlich voran
und ich finde das einige ganz kluge
Aspekte doch hier schon gesammelt worden
sind ich teile was Carsten Linnemann
gesagt hat es wird keine Gesellschaft
auf der Welt oder in der Geschichte
geben die ihren Wohlstand sichert indem
sie weniger arbeitet nicht vor vier Tage
Woche aber zugleich haben wir doch auch
strukturelle Probleme die ehrlich gesagt
nicht erst seit gestern bestehen sondern
schon länger
Fachkräfte Einwanderung aus der
Kernenergie und der Kohle ist
Deutschland ausgestiegen unter Führung
der Union ohne dass der Einstieg in
alternativen klar gewesen wäre müssen
wir jetzt gemeinsam das Problem lösen
wir haben einen kassierenden
Bürokratismus viel davon kommt aus
Brüssel unter auchführung einer
cdu-kommissionspräsidentin aber es hilft
uns doch jetzt nicht zu sagen die oder
die oder der ist schuld sondern warum
die ganze Zeit die sind schuld die sind
schon das sage ich versuche die ganze
Zeit hier in der Sendung im Sinne dessen
was der Kanzler packt für Deutschland
oder deutschlandpack nennt zu sagen wir
müssen Dinge lösen und ich mache es
normal an einem Beispiel dass ich eben
kurz angesprochen habe deutlich jetzt
haben wir einen Wachstumschancen gesetzt
Investitionen Forschung sondern gestärkt
werden Mittelstand wird entlastet 32
Milliarden Euro Entlastungsvolumen ich
finde das ist nicht nichts zugleich aber
gefährdet ist nicht gefährdet ist nicht
die Inflationsbekämpfung durch
zu starke Schulden finanzierte
Konjunktur stützen und jetzt sagen
Ministerpräsidenten der Länder aus
Bremen aus Berlin aus Schleswig-Holstein
wir wollen das nicht wir können uns das
nicht leisten wir können wir wollen das
nicht und da sage ich wenn dieses Land
weiter ein sozialen Anspruch haben will
wenn dieses Land weiter ökologische
Ziele haben muss dann geht es nur durch
ein stabiles wirtschaftliches Fundament
und dann müssen Bund und Länder
gemeinsam Verantwortung weil die
natürlich nicht einfach sagen dieses
Gesetz wollen wir nicht sondern sie
möchten das Essen oder möchten die Messe
nicht bezahlen weil sie sagen wenn der
Bund dieses Programm auflegt und aber zu
50% die Länder einen Plan möchten wir
wenigstens einbezogen werden aber die
Länder profitieren doch auch wenn die
Steuereinnahmen aufgrund eines solchen
Gesetzes und stärkeren Wachstums steigen
wir sind doch da in in einem Boot ich
meine die Wahrheit ist dass die Länder
die Energiepreise zunächst dran wollen
weil sie sagen die Energiepreise sind so
hoch die Industrie wandert ab die
energieintensivindustrie und darüber
wollen
wir in Zukunft Geld ausgeben der Streit
darüber wird in der Ampel weitergehen es
finden sich neue Bündnisse das werden
Sie gleich sehen denn das Geld wird
tatsächlich auch knapper ist das richtig
was ich machen
mit stolz geschwellter Brust das zweite
Jahr in Folge
[Musik]
Mr Schuldenbremse freut sich wie Bolle
über sein Haushalt und tatsächlich
einzig und allein ihre kleine Fraktion
hier in der Mitte hat ihn Applaus
gespendet spätestens seit gestern haben
wir also zwei Oppositionsführer in
Deutschland einen im Parlament und einen
in der Regierung auf gute Zusammenarbeit
Christian Lindner kann ich da nur
aber ist Mister Schuldenbremse wirklich
der für den er sich ausgibt
gut 16 Milliarden neue Schulden stehen
im Haushalt offiziell
laut Bundesrechnungshof nimmt der Staat
aber de facto über 85 Milliarden auf
verschleiert durch 29 Schattenhaushalte
wie dem Sondervermögen Bundeswehr durch
diese Art töpfchenwirtschaft hat der
Bundestag als Haushaltsgesetzgeber
gerade keinen klaren Blick mehr auf die
tatsächliche Lage der Bundesfinanzen
der nicht spart den Vorwurf macht ihn
nicht nur Herr Lindemann sondern auch
der Bundesrechnungshof und beide nehmen
sie nicht ab
ich nehme jede Kritik ernst aber ich
habe starke Verbündete nämlich die
Zahlen in den nächsten Jahren wird die
Schuldenquote in Deutschland sinken das
heißt wenn wir den Bundeshaushalt nehmen
und alle Sondervermögen also das
Sonderprogramm für die Bundeswehr oder
den Klima und transformationsfonds die
Schuldenquote unseres Landes sinkt und
damit ist ganz klar Deutschland
entwickelt sich aus einer Phase der
expansiven Finanzpolitik und steigender
Staatsverschuldung jetzt zurück in
Richtung des vorkrisen-niveaus wir
werden noch im Laufe dieses Jahrzehnts
in die Zeit der Verschuldung vor der
corona-pandemie zurückkehren schneller
als viele denken nochmal zurück der
Bundesrechnungshof sagt es ist nicht
verfassungskonform wenn das Parlament
nicht mehr nachvollziehen kann aus
welchem Topf Milliarden Kommen und Gehen
es ist ein einziges kommen diese Kritik
ist
also vorsichtig gesagt überraschend denn
von diesen 29 Sondervermögen ist ja der
weit über steigende Teil in den letzten
Jahrzehnten entstanden übrigens aus
gutem Gründen warum macht man das das
Sondervermögen wie es heißt für die
Flutopfer in Rheinland-Pfalz und
Nordrhein-Westfalen wurde eingerichtet
wurde eingerichtet weil über eine
längere Zeit Menschen unterstützt werden
sollen beispielsweise das Sondervermögen
für die Strom und die gaspreisbremse
musste für die Jahre 22 bis 24 in einem
ausfinanziert werden für alle drei Jahre
warum weil wir die Entwicklung der
Strom- und Gaspreise nicht voraussehen
konnten man wusste nicht zu welchem
Zeitpunkt ist wie viel Geld nötig
übrigens viel weniger als gedacht und
jetzt Leuten sie eine Phase einen in der
Sie diese kriseninstrumente so sagen sie
ist Herr Lindner diese kriseninstrumente
zurückfahren wollen und sagen auf der
anderen Seite aber dass wir uns in einer
echten Krise befinden oder ist die Krise
vorbei sorry wenn ich das Frage ist die
Krise vorbei nein wir haben weiter
strukturelle Herausforderungen
aber eine Ausnahme von der
Schuldenbremse ist nur bei Fragen
gestattet die außerhalb der
Einflussmöglichkeit des Staates liegen
das Lehrbuchbeispiel dafür ist eine
Naturkatastrophe die Anpassungsprobleme
die wir in Deutschland haben Strompreis
zum Beispiel das ist in der
einflussfähre des Staates da können wir
handeln das ist auch nicht plötzlich
sondern es eine Herausforderung die
strukturelles für die nächsten Jahre und
deshalb die
kriseninstrumente die wir haben die
Strom und gaspreisbremse die will ich
gar nicht beenden die laufen automatisch
aus die sind zeitlich befristet und mit
der Schuldenbremse im Bundeshaushalt und
den auslaufenden krisenhilfen werden wir
sagen es noch mal in den nächsten Jahren
erleben dass ab jetzt die Schuldenquote
runterzählen und nicht steigt und welche
Position und welche Zustimmung bekommen
sie dafür für diesen Plan innerhalb der
Ampel und gleich von den Grünen werden
wir fragen aber noch mal zu dem hüb
Punkt des Friedrich Merz findet dass sie
nicht nur beim Wärmegesetz als uns
gesetzt sondern auch in dieser Frage in
prima Oppositionsführer abgeben das war
eine unterhaltsame per Ernte aber die
Situation ist ja dass wir uns als
Bundeskabinett nach einem
zugegebenermaßen intensiven
Arbeitsprozess ja auf diesen Entwurf
geeinigt haben und um das die um das
auch noch mal noch mal vielleicht in
einem Zusammenhang zu stellen
verglichen mit dem Jahr 2019 haben wir
25 Prozent mehr Staatsausgaben das heißt
wir haben jetzt Diskussionen und es gibt
auch Kritik aus von Sozialverbänden oder
aus der Wirtschaft obwohl wir sehr viel
mehr ausgeben als vorher weshalb ich
glaube dass wir uns über die Pandemie
und über den energiepreisschock des
vergangenen Jahres an einen Staat
gewöhnt haben der überall sich einmischt
und der überall versucht mit Geld in
Anführungsstrichen zu helfen und das ist
auf Dauer nicht finanzierbar Milliarden
für den
klimatransformationsfonds für die
Verteidigung 100 Milliarden nochmal 200
Milliarden für den
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfond die
wollen sie nicht komplett abrufen
übrigens wenn man so sagen muss man noch
ergänzen die 211 Milliarden für den
Klima- und transformationsfonds das sind
nicht alles jetzt neue Schulden sind
Rücklagen der Vorgängerregierung von
cdu/csu geführt und der Klima-
also wir zahlen ja Geld für die
CO2-Emissionen jeder von uns wird CO2
ich muss nur erklären der CO2 ausstößt
zahlt in dieser Einnahmen gehen in den
KTF und aus dem KTF werden nun Maßnahmen
finanziert die die
Transformation erleichtern dass also CO2
eingespart wird Geld noch da sein ich
habe mir ich habe mir gerade kurz
vorgestellt was ein echter
Oppositionspolitiker Christian Lindner
zu diesem Haushalt gesagt hätte das wäre
Schattenhaushalt und töpfchenwirtschaft
sicherlich noch das wenigste gewesen
also diese Schuldenbremse ist schon eine
Scharade ich verstehe aber warum Herr
Lindner daran so festhält und da bin ich
dann bei Ihrer Frage wofür kann man Geld
noch ausgeben erhält natürlich daran
fest um die anderen Parteien in der
Regierung damit zu disziplinieren dass
eben nicht so viele Ausgaben Wünsche an
ihnen herangetragen werden bzw das aber
Ausgaben wünschen sagen kann können wir
nicht machen und wofür kann man noch
Geld ausgeben für gezielte Maßnahmen ich
finde beispielsweise auch das
wachstumschancengesetz um auch mal was
positives zu sagen eine sehr gute Idee
dass man dann zum sagt der gerade lahm
denn Immobilienwirtschaft
Immobilienwirtschaft
Immobilienwirtschaft Bauwirtschaft die
bekommt jetzt Steuererleichterung also
Sonderabschreibungen und soll dann eben
loslegen und sofort Wohnungen bauen das
hilft dann an beiden Enden das hilft der
Bauwirtschaft und das hilft natürlich
auch bei dem total knappen Wohnraum in
Deutschland das sind so Beispiel
gezielter ansetzen und wenn man über den
Sozialstaat spricht dann
müssen eben gezielt die Menschen die
tatsächlich auf Hilfe angewiesen sind
und die sich nicht selber helfen können
die brauchen natürlich Solidarität und
Unterstützung aber auch da haben wir uns
in den vergangenen bei den vergangenen
Regierungen zu sehr daran gewöhnt dass
der sozialstand doch Staat doch auch
sehr expansiv gewesen ist es hat
zusätzliche Leistungen gegeben für die
Rente für die Gesundheit für die Pflege
manches war notwendig aber manches war
auch tatsächlich ja über den Durst war
Luxus der uns dann auch heute wehtut und
der heute schwierig ist
durchzufinanzieren wir sind Frau lang
bei der zentralen Frage ob diese
Streitereien jetzt weitergehen sie
könnten beispielsweise weitergehen bei
der Frage um die sozialen Reformen die
noch vor uns stehen da gibt es die gute
Äußerung oder auch nicht so gute
Äußerung der FDP zu sagen diese
Kindergrundsicherung war die letzte
große Sozialreform die gemacht haben
gesagt Tiere Wünsche gehen da weiter
weil sie sich auch noch eine
Rentenreform wünschen weil sie sich auch
noch weitergehende Maßnahmen für die
Kindergrundsicherung wünschen ich glaube
die Rentenreform wünschte ich nicht
Ricarda lang sondern auf die haben uns
gemeinsam geeinigt und ich halte da gar
nichts von so eine etikettendebatte wir
machen jetzt nichts mehr nach sozialen
wir machen nichts mehr da ist mir
angetreten um die Probleme zu lösen die
Daten damals darauf geeinigt dass zum
Beispiel wie eine Rentenreform auf den
Weg bringen wollen wo man sowohl das
Rentenniveau stabilisiert als auch die
aktienrente gemeinsam angeht als
Ergänzung zu den
Sozialversicherungssystem also da wird
als Ampel noch einiges kommen zweites
Thema was ich gerade angesprochen habe
ist die Tarif Treue als wäre es auch
dafür sorgen dass die Menschen die hart
arbeiten dann auch bessere Löhne haben
ich würde aber schon sagen zu dem was
sie da gesagt haben Frau Quadbeck gerade
in Zeiten wo die Preise steigern ist ein
starker Sozialstaat doch auch wenn wir
auf die Demokratie schauen extrem
wichtig sie haben selbst angesprochen
dort wo es zu uns Sicherheit kommt
gerade in Krisenzeiten dort wo das
Gefühl kommt ich bleibe vielleicht auf
der Strecke wächst auch der Zweifel an
demokratischen Situationen an der
Demokratie das heißt für mich ist schon
klar mehr Gerechtigkeit und auch ein
starkes Sozialstaat sind gerade in
diesen Zeiten wichtig und sind auch ein
Schutz der Demokratie wir sind eine
Story noch ein bisschen umdrehen auch
also das wäre Sozialstaat nur expandiert
und die Menschen sich daran gewöhnt
haben der Staat richtet schon alles da
gibt es ja auch eine andere Seite der
Geschichte und die lautet eben das laut
Hochrechnung von uns 12 Milliarden Euro
aus Pflegeleistung überhaupt nicht
abgerufen werden von den Menschen das
Bildungs- und Teilhabe Leistung und für
arme Familien nur von 35% der
Berechtigten abgerufen werden weil es
viel zu kompliziert ist also die
Geschichte ist schon ein bisschen
komplexer finde ich als nur zu sagen die
Menschen gewöhnen sich daran dass hier
jeder nur was kriegt der eigentlich der
ist vielleicht nicht unbedingt braucht
oder der sich nicht anstrengen will das
ist ja nicht das Wesen und der Grundsatz
von dem solidarischen Sozialstaat soll
und Wesen ist schon eher dass der Staat
eben hier eine Funktion haben sollte
gerade was mit der Kindergrundsicherung
gerade passiert dass die Menschen die
wirklich Unterstützung brauchen denen
halt auch nicht geholfen ist wo keiner
was gegen hat zu sagen die Eltern sollen
in Arbeit gebracht werden habe ich
überhaupt nichts gegen finde ich eine
super Idee nur wenn Kinder jetzt im
Moment Abend sind bringt ihnen das
herzlich wenig wenn ihre Eltern
vielleicht in Bayern in arbeiten kommen
sondern die brauchen jetzt eine
Unterstützung um an Bildung und Teilhabe
Teil so und da ist genau das politische
Problem gewesen dass Frau Pause ich
glaube freundlich formuliert mehrere
Zahlen im Angebot hatte um dann bei 2,4
Milliarden für die Kinder Grundsicherung
zu landen das ist von ihnen schon
öffentlich nicht besonders gut und
glücklich besprochen worden was in aller
erster Linie nicht schön für die Grünen
aber in alle allererste Linie auch eine
Blamage für Robert habe nein überhaupt
nicht am Ende haben wir gemeinsam als
Ampel beides hinbekommen wachsen
chancengesetz und eine Kinder
Grundsicherung bei der
Kindergrundsicherung muss man sich
anschauen das ist ja auch ein Paket aus
der Kindergeld Erhöhung die wir jetzt am
Ende dieses Jahr auf den Weg gebracht
haben aus die Kinder Grundsicherung und
aus der Erhöhung der Regelsätze also für
die Kinder die armutsgefährdet sind als
Reaktion auf die Inflation was aber bei
allen dem wichtig ist und das haben sie
ja gerade auch angesprochen über die ob
die Leute das überhaupt abrufen also ob
Sie zu Ihrem Recht kommen ist das da wo
der soziale Staat was leisten insgesamt
der Staat das leistet ist auch
funktionieren muss und das ist für mich
der Paradigmenwechsel hinter dieser
Kindergrundsicherung ein Systemwandel
weg von der hohlschuld wo die Familien
sich durch einen Bürokratie Dschungel
durchkämpfen müssen hin zu einer
Bringschuld und ich glaube übrigens wir
können viel über die Finanzen
diskutieren das ist auch wichtig aber da
kommen wir sehr schnell sehr gut
zusammen wir brauchen einen massiven
Bürokratieabbau das heißt von den
sozialen Kassen bis hin zum
Handwerksunternehmen ist übrigens ein
Volkshochschulen die Integrationskurse
anbieten alle echten unter zu viel
papierstab mehr Digitalisierung mehr
Praxis Checks einfache Verfahren das
würde auch bei der sozialen Politik
helfen die Kinder Grundsicherung zum
Beispiel dafür interessant weil die
Kinder Grundsicherung ja über 2
Milliarden veranschlagt und die exper
Menschen sagen dass 500 Millionen
Bürokratie ist also sie sagen sie wollen
Bürokratie abbauen verabschieden ein
Gesetz was zu einem Viertel ein Fünftel
Bürokratie verursacht das ist ja irre
das kann ich gar nicht
ich das sagen die das sagen die Städte
Gemeinden Kommunen wenn ich mit den Rede
und ich glaube deshalb muss man Gesetze
machen wo man nicht Bürokratie aufbaut
sondern abbaut vielleicht sogar mit
Verfallsdatum und gleichzeitig Momente
aber vielleicht besprechen den Kindern
175 Familien und kinderpolitische
Leistung bisher in diesem Land die
werden jetzt endlich mal gebündelt damit
eben nicht mehr die Familien von einem
steht 500 Millionen Euro
was was davor kinderarmut ist nicht erst
seit gestern stehen auch nicht dass
diese ampelregierung da ist das wissen
wir seit langer Zeit es wurde nie eine
strukturelle Antwort darauf gefunden
jetzt wird die mit dieser Ampel endlich
gefunden
noch Geld da sein es gibt sehr Lindemann
natürlich die Sehnsüchte der Bürger
weiter die Energie gestützt zu bekommen
die laufen aus hat Herr Lindner gerade
gesagt Gast und strompreisbremse sind
zum Ende des Jahres Weg wie sehr denken
sie müssen auch weiter die Energiepreise
noch gestützt werden oder sollen sie sie
nur für die energieintensive Industrie
also das Problem ist ja bei der Energie
dass wir zu wenig Angebot dann Energie
haben also wenn wir jetzt einfach nur
Stützen bleibt ja das Problem gleich
weil zu wenig Angebote da ist das hatten
wir gerade schon richtig genau wie sehr
hier ist morgen eingesetzt machen und
die Stromsteuer fast abschaffen da
gibt's so ein geringes Niveau was Europa
vorgibt und dann hätten wir sofort für
die die Stromsteuer und werden sofort
für die kompletten Mittelstand eine
Entlastung wir könnten die stromentgelte
dran wir könnten sofort loslegen und ich
sage an dieser Stelle ganz klar wenn der
Lindner morgen das Gesetz vorliegt bei
der Stromsteuer stimmen wir zu ich würde
es gerne machen wo kommen die 8
Milliarden wie das kostet ja
also wenn dieses Land
im Durchschnitt so wachsen würde wie
jetzt Europa wächst hätten wir 20
Milliarden mehr zweiter Punkt wenn wir
die bürgerweltreform so machen würden
wie es Frau Bentele gesagt hat dass wir
uns auf die konzentrieren die wirklich
nicht arbeiten können und da gibt es
viele die unverschuldet in die
Arbeitslosigkeit gehen es gibt viele die
handwerklich nicht mehr können nach 40
Jahren aber ich möchte im Umkehrschluss
dass wir in Deutschland ein System haben
wie Dänemark wie in den Niederlanden da
gibt's gar kein Aufschrei der Entrüstung
dass derjenige der Arbeiten kann auch
arbeiten gehen muss dass er warten die
Menschen die jeden Tag arbeiten und mit
ihren Steuern unseren Sozialstaat erst
fähig machen und 100.000 z.B bringen
sind das zwei bis drei Milliarden Euro
mehr das wäre meine
Vorschlag also dass das anders Leitbild
eines aktivierenden Sozialstaats Teile
nicht nur ich sondern auch wir als
Koalition die Ernte des Bürgergeldes ist
ja dass ich Leistung stärker Lohn ich
mach mal das Beispiel die Auszubildende
mit dem alten Hartz-IV-System die 800
Euro Ausbildungsvergütung bekommen hat
die musste 600 Euro abgeben jetzt behält
sie 600 Euro das ist also
leistungsorientiert ich könnte weitere
Beispiele nennen nur wir können jetzt
diese diese abstrakte Diskussion führen
wie bauen wie bauen wir Systeme
insgesamt um nur wenn man sagt jetzt
8 Milliarden Euro Stromsteuer gegen
finanziert werden dann geht das nicht
damit dass man sagt wir werden der einst
in der Zukunft höheres Wachstum haben
morgen die Bürger Geldreform zustimmen
unter Lindner vielleicht was auch
wichtig ist auch mit besten Beispiel
vorangeht ich meine es sind 1000 800
Angestellte im öffentlichen Dienst und
Beamte in den Bundesministerien allein
in zwei Jahren bitte eingestellt worden
so okay so zusätzlich warum kann der
Staat nicht mal bei sich selbst anfangen
wir haben bis zu 50 Bundesbeauftragte
das Kanzleramt wieder dabei diskutieren
weil die CDU ist ja ein bisschen wie
eine Wundertüte man kann jede Position
bekommen wenn man irgendwie reinfasst
und gestern haben sich ja erst die
Ministerpräsidenten übrigens auch alle
Ministerpräsidenten der Union dafür
ausgesprochen dass es ein
industriestrompreis ein
brückenstrompreis gibt ich glaube wir
sind einig wir haben zu hohe Energie
Fragen ich spreche gerade die
Ministerpräsident wir sind da sehr sehr
klar als grüne auch die der Union dass
wir eine Brücke brauchen für die
nächsten Jahre wo wir wettbewerbsfähig
mäßig relativ hohe Industriepreise haben
vor allem wenn wir auf die
Grundstoffindustrie schauen und das
hätte den Vorteil der Planungssicherheit
das hätte den Vorteil dass
Investitionsentscheidung nicht ins
Ausland verlagert werden sondern hier
getroffen werden
darüber zu reden wie man am besten die
Lösung findet ich glaube das werden wir
auch nicht hier in der Talkshow machen
sondern innerhalb der Koalition am Ende
muss man aber sehen da hängen verdammt
viele Arbeitsplätze dran Industrie eine
Million auch noch mal die geographische
linke Seite Frau langen sie haben
versprochen die Regierung hat gesprochen
das ist weil es eine co2-preiserhöhung
geben wird ab dem kommenden Jahr nicht
mehr 30 Euro die Tonne sondern 40 Euro
die Tonne CO2-Emissionen auf Öl und die
hässlichen fossilen Stinker das ist ein
klimagat geben wird dass die Menschen
die da besonders sparen ein Klima Geld
bekommen KTF hat er schon gesagt
Auszahlung an die Bürger dieses
Versprechen sind sie schuldig mit der
Begründung des Bundeskanzlers das leider
kein Geld da ist es gibt eine
Negativbilanz die Abschaffung der
eg-umlage hat 20 Milliarden gekostet
wann kommt für die Menschen in diesem
Land er ist der erste Preise steigen die
Kompensation Klima Geld also erstmal
sind wir etwas im preisfahrt angeht
Stück für Stück gehen wir wieder in
Richtung der bei der großen Koalition
schon vorgesehen war drunter da wäre ein
Jahr ausgesetzt haben letztes Jahr wegen
der Inflation wo kein Klima Geld
vorgesehen war und jetzt bringen wir es
auf den Weg Christian Lindner kann Ihnen
die Frage glaube ich am genauesten
beantworten wann der
auszahlungsmechanismus fertig ist aber
ich bin mir sicher da freut sich am Ende
dieser Koalition nein das ist ja also
das ist ja gar nicht so ein großer
Streitpunkt sondern wir werden am Ende
dieser Koalition gemeinsam ein
Klimagerät auf den Weg gebracht haben
und das wird dauerhaft den Weg beim
Klimaschutz absichern und das ist ja
klar dass wenn wir auf Preissignale
setzen was richtig ist aus Marktlogik
heraus dann braucht es auch ein sozialen
Ausgleich und der wird dem wird die
Ablauf den Weg bringen und den haben sie
versprochen glauben sie noch dran dass
das Klima Geld ab 1 Uhr zurückgezahlt
wird an die Bürgermeister das war auch
nie versprochen nein okay nein das war
nie versprochen also zunächst mal der
auszahlungsmechanismus wie es so im im
verwaltungsdeutsch heißt der wird Ende
des Jahres 2024 zur Verfügung stehen
eine ganz große Innovation nein das bin
ich und es ist eine ganz große
Innovation weil die Möglichkeit dass man
an diejenigen die eine
Steueridentifikationsnummer hat dass man
an deren deren IBAN an deren
bankenverbindung etwas überweist das gab
es noch nie eine ganz innovative neue
Sache und wir müssen auch die Daten erst
einmal haben und die entsprechende
IT-Infrastruktur aber die Koalition Geld
für die Studenten
Notwendigkeiten sehen Sie von wo wir von
wo wir kommen von wo wir kommen und was
da jetzt dann möglich wird aber die
Koalition hat nie gesagt dass zum ersten
ersten 24 oder 25 das kommt sondern
negativ Bilanz es ist kein Grund dafür
da aber es war auch auch 2021 beim
Abschluss des Koalitionsvertrages nie
die Rede davon dass ab 1 24 oder 25 das
kommt sondern am Ende am Ende eines
Preises für Gas sind okay Preise für
Strom sind sehr hoch Preise für Öl sind
okay die werden wieder steigen Herr
Lindner wie kompensieren sie für die
Menschen diese Energiepreise ist meine
Frage das wo der Staat
zusätzlich politisch gewollt verteuert
ist 5 Euro weniger pro Tonne im nächsten
Jahr als der preisfahrt der
Vorgängerregierung das heißt die
künstliche politische Verteuerung haben
wir zunächst einmal reduziert weil das
Preisniveau insgesamt höher ist als es
früher erwartet worden war aufgrund der
Situation nach dem Ukraine Krieg und
dann müssen wir sehr klar sagen wir
haben keine andere Chance als das
Angebot an Energie auszuweiten es macht
auch eine Subventionierung nach meiner
Überzeugung für z.B die energieintensive
Wirtschaft die großen Betriebe keinen
Sinn weil die Bürgerinnen und Bürger und
der Mittelstand würden für einige wenige
die subventionierten Strompreise
bezahlen und die subventionierten
Unternehmen würden in den knappen Markt
hinein ihren Verbrauch Leben
das heißt es würde zusätzlich für alle
anderen auch noch teurer werden und ich
so sehr ich mich freue über die
Diskussion über die Energiepreise hätte
ich das gerne einige Monate zuvor gehabt
als wir diskutiert haben über 30
Terawattstunden günstige
klimafreundliche Kernenergie da ist
schon wieder das AKW alles klar dreimal
in dieser Sendung und wir fragen vor
Quadbeck zum Schluss in welcher Art und
Weise denken sie kommen wir in den
heißen Herbst der Streit hört nicht auf
also ich bin nicht zuversichtlich dass
der Streit aufhört mal gucken wie jetzt
das Gesetz zur Kindergrundsicherung nach
Hause geschaukelt wird da sind aus
meiner Sicht auch wirklich noch nicht
alle offenen Fragen beantwortet
dann ist es wann im Kabinett ich gehe
davon aus in der nächsten
Kabinettssitzung kann das sein die
technischen Umsetzungsfragen werden von
den Beamtinnen und Beamten gelöst
politisch gab es keinen dessens also ich
bin trotzdem nicht zuversichtlich dass
der Streit aufhört
allerdings die Not ist groß und der
Kanzler hat ja das Wort von dem
Schalldämpfer haben sie zum Beginn der
Sendung gezeigt gesagt und ähm es wird
sich erweisen ob diese Botschaft
angekommen ist und ob es eben gelingt
den Streit stärker hinter den Kulissen
auszuführen im Kanzleramt sagt man ja
immer Gesetze machen sei wie Wurst
machen ist nicht schön wenn man dabei
zusehen muss und ich glaube da ähm hat
das Publikum inzwischen tatsächlich
genug für das stimmt aber man während
der ihrer Merkel und sie Verkäufer kann
mir gerade auch Bezug darauf genommen da
wurde beklagt alles wird mit Geld
zugeschüttet der politische Diskurs ist
nach kurtisiert die Unterschiede
zwischen CDU und CSU und SPD
verschwimmen
deshalb wird die AFD stark so war das
alte narrativ jetzt haben wir Parteien
im demokratischen Zentrum grüne cdu/csu
sPD FDP die zeigen es gibt Unterschiede
es wird gerungen es macht einen
Unterschied ob du grün wählst oder
schwarz oder rot oder gelbst macht
wirklich einen Unterschied und das
gefällt dann auch wieder aber
ihren kleinen wir brauchen einen
souveräneren Umgang auch mit politischen
Unterschieden weil warum haben wir einen
Wahlrecht deshalb weil sich wählen lohnt
weil es unterschiedliche Ansätze gibt es
ist eben nur so wichtig in der Regierung
dass man sich bei unterschiedlichen
Auffassungen eben auf etwas einigt und
nicht bei den eigenen Plänen bleibt
schaffen wir ja immer ich mach mal einen
Punkt bedanke mich ganz herzlich für die
Diskussion hier heute wir sehen uns wenn
Sie mögen live und in fahren
der unter anderem Thorsten frei zu Gast
hat von der CDU und Michael Brücke und
überhaupt lauter tolle Leute kommen sie
gut durch diese Nacht tschüss vielen
lieben Dank
[Musik]